Mì bụt thằng ta, cũng đồ is rangeo biết đã đánh chẳng thành công một tên lửa phòng từ emen.
Sao đồ lựng lựng lựa hụt thì nhận chân nghiệp,
tương bố đã phòng tên lửa đã đạo xíu thành Phalestine 2, nhằm vào sinh bay bên buồn.
Tư đò kế tục trôi thành công nhằm thấy những tình thành đoàn két,
tựa như Phalestine, tại giải gà ra.
Cũng lên quan tới cuộc xung đồn này.
Cũng ngay, mì bụt thằng ta, hơn một chăm tổ chức phía lệ vật,
trong đồn của Aus Farm K và tổ chức Vác Sỳ không bình dưới.
Đã a ra, tuần bố chung, cạnh báo rằng các quy định mới của Isran Bay hạt lộn gịt trợ tại giải gà ra và mở tây.
Đăng làm chỉ hoản các hạt lộn phía chờ,
tông thời gà mục Isran đang vũ khi hoàn hàng về chờ với việc thay thế các tổ chức nhìn đạo của tế,
bằng tổ chức hạt E, trong tình bố chung, kể tuần khi Isran A trộn quy định kìm xóa hồi thằng ba,
số lượng hàng hòa viện trợ vào giải gà ra là quả ít,
trong bù đáp tổng như cầu tối thiệu của người pelestine tại đây,
nhiều này khiến số người chết vì đoại tăng lên gần hai trong bố mình người,
trong nó của một trong lệ sảo chế em.
Căng thằng về việc hạnh trế vinc yên chờ,
kết hợp với cuộc khủng hàng nhìn đạo nghiêm trọng đã khiến nhiều cuu raf tôn tây,
tốt đầy cầm nhận nhá nước pelestine trong thời gian đầy.
khiến tổng số người gà ra thiệt mạng tính tự khi xuống đột khởi phát,
đã vừa sọng mối ngình, mấy trong người, trong nó còn nhiều phụ nữ và chế em.